Vì bây măng này, đây là bị chỉ ông về măng này.
Bây giờ, thế thì phải chỉ ông về măng này, phải là măng này.
Đúng không? Bà có xu hướng tăng.
Bây giờ, thì phát tơ có thể ngay.
Em không thể ngay.
Xu hướng tăng này là xu hướng tăng của địa qua nhà phụ bất tốt.
Búng không? Còn muốn biết là có tơ tăng khi nào,
có thể như ở lâu đi về chỉ biết của tốt.
Hình rất ngủ tốt, quá.
Cái sao trong cái tơ này này, thì phải tụi này đang có xu hướng tăng.
Đáng, muốn đi theo, đang xu, đi về việc chỉ phát tơ.
Đi đây chỉ là khơi điểm tây, bằng không phải xấu đời.
Còn các đam muốn xấu đi phát tơ, thì đúng là,
phát tơ có các khởi bệnh rất đỏ và trục đối.
Đúng không? Đổi đầy trụ quý vị này, đầy trụ đỏ này,
đi phát tụi nó không?
Đúng không?
Để không phải phát tộng, đúng không?
Đúng không? Cái gì? Đúng không?
Cái gì? Cái gì? Cái gì? Cái gì?
Cái gì? Cái gì? Cái gì?
Cái gì? Cái gì?
Cái gì?